[Musica]
diventare un'altra persona
cambiando fa bella che sta lì ma è
questa
mi prende in giro bella we are trader
man
siamo uomini tradotti siamo fatti di più
lingue più costrutti più lingue più
strade più metri da cambiare
altre porte da aprire alberi da chiamare
are bad boy man diventare altro da me
guardare guardarti guardarmi nella
lingua prossima alla mia lingua che
diventa mia me che divento lingua langhe
strafà zung e tiri salvarmi dal delirio
mono linguistico monoculturale
monocultura banane banane banane banane
banane banane banane banane banane
banana e banane banane banane e lampone
caffè sfociare in altri me lasciare
libere altre impressioni di me
wirth li skype spath herlitzka it was
the toilet e allo stesso tempo il
writing session di tradurre da a
tradurre in con su per tra fra strafare
stargate verso questo mondo gira salta
equilibra sposta un verbo crea un nuovo
embrio excalibur calembour 2x2 fa tretto
giur
tendere l'arco del torneo puntare la
freccia e iniziare a sbagliare
per centrare il bersaglio iniziare a
sbadigliare iniziare a balbettare nuove
lingue iniziare a baciare con un kit è
confronto è conforto vagare in un'altra
lingua alla ricerca del soggetto che
cosa si prova a trovarsi improvvisamente
in un'altra posizione
anarchia grammaticale spostare soggetti
verbi avverbi affissi circum fissi e
trovare nuovi posti per il proprio seme
improvvisamente non sono più sola ci
sono io e ana ea hai tutto è implicito
tutto è esplicito tutto si governa da sé
e tutto si trasforma quando vado
dall'altra parte nell'altra lingua dove
ci sei tu che mi stia aspettando tutto
tu anta anti ti più avvertire un suono
nuovo sovvertire il mio modo di pensare
trovare nuove soluzioni tradurre e
tradirsi sempre idratata applicata che
da cota che da un grazie
[Applauso]